so I'm Dano Clifford I lead the team at
Google Munich in Germany that works on
v8 which is a JavaScript engine you
might have heard of that is used both in
Google Chrome and in nodejs so I'm gonna
ask for a little bit of audience
participation here who has actually
written JavaScript on the client side
that's good all right
server side Wow all right good who's
actually heard of the 8 all right so
that's good all right good so before I
get into the actual mute of my talk I'd
like to sort of set the frame for the
discussion and the topics that I'd like
to share with you today and it's a
little bit mccoshen Airy tale so I've
been in this industry for almost all
more than 25 years and I've seen a lot
of dreams come true and not all of those
dreams have worked out quite the way you
expected and so the quote that I'd like
to share with you to start out with is
beware of what you're wishing for in you
because you may get in your middle age
so this quote actually is attributed to
a relatively famous sometimes lyric poet
and philosopher and statesman johann
wolfgang von goethe and it's kind of
attributed as the source of a little bit
more common phrase that you may have
heard of as well which is be careful
what you wish for in life because it
might come true and the reason I give
that context right now is it turns out
that a significantly less well-known
philosopher and not very talented a
writer actually had a quote that is very
applicable in our space as software
developers and sort of and product and
developers of complex systems and that
goes something like this
be careful what you optimize because it
might get faster and nothing else so
keep that in mind as sort of the frame
for the discussion I'd like to have
today with you and with that I'd like to
show you my overview
it's an overview
I like to start out with it's funny it's
I'd like to talk I'd like to start out
with something that I make it sound
really official called the synthetic
benchmark dilemma this is how benchmarks
can go bad I'd like to talk to you a
little bit about how v8 works and how
that's changed over the last couple
years especially because it gives a
frame for how the lessons that we've
learned over the last couple years and I
think there's actually lessons here that
are applicable to development of any
large software system the lessons
learned of course an important part of
this and what I like to sort of focus on
is this thing called self hosted versus
optimized built-ins and I'll get into
what that is so don't worry about at
this point and the last thing like to do
is tell you about what we did once we
figured out that the lesson we had
learned was important we did something
about it and this is the section called
building a builder built-in and the code
stop assembler so let's get into it the
synthetic benchmark dilemma I'd like to
take a little walk down memory lane here
vietze been around for a while now when
it first came out when chrome was first
released the benchmarks that were used
to test JavaScript speed were what we'd
now in retrospect called micro
benchmarks so SunSpider kracken they
were useful at the time because they
tested certain key functionality of the
JavaScript runtime which was important
for small applications to have run
quickly as applications grew bigger and
v8 was responsible for part of this that
applications become could become more
complex the type of thick that needed to
be tested for in benchmarks also became
bigger so around 2012 or in 2012 we
released a benchmark called octane and
it tried to represent a broader spectrum
of usage use cases that we could
optimize for so that we would do a
better job of actually optimizing for
the applications that we we found and
find in the wild it turns out that
we have a quite gotten it right a v8 did
a really good job of optimizing the
benchmarks that we had so SunSpider
kracken octane but it's important we
realize that those benchmark didn't
really reflect what was going on in the
wild and so we created a internal
benchmark where common websites and we
ran them through some automation that we
built and we measured exactly where they
were spending their time and there was
some interesting results that came out
of this so this looks really complicated
and you don't have to understand all the
details here but what I like to point
out is on the left-hand side is a list
of a bunch of websites and probably
difficult to read from way in the back
row but some of those might look
familiar to you and each of these bars
next to the website is a distribution of
time what chrome is actually doing when
you're loading that website and we
created these tests so that we could run
them again and again be able to do
optimizations and see how these profiles
would change the thing to notice here is
on the bottom there's a legend and
you'll see that the time that we spent
on websites was really kind of across
the board we spent some time in
JavaScript but we also spend time in
callbacks that's blink that's in the Dom
for example we also spent time parsing
I'll get back to that or I'll show that
where that fits in later and there was a
various other things that we were doing
when we were loading the websites now
the interesting thing here is you see
that every website is a little bit
different but you do see some patterns
here or at what at least one pattern
that was very interesting to us and that
is the pinkish bar on the right is
relatively small it's 25% or less on all
of the websites that we tested and that
came as a surprise because that's the
JavaScript piece that's the time spent
actually executing JavaScript and why is
this interesting
well if you take a look at octant octane
the benchmark we came out and with in
look where octane spends its time right
it's almost all pink or two-thirds
three-quarters pink which means what we
were optimizing for for many years was
not actually representative of what is
out there in the web
okay so that's something we need to fix
and over the last couple of years we've
been working hard to fix that and the
way we've done this is try to look more
at real websites and on the server side
at nodejs performance in real
applications so that we can tune v8 for
the type of workloads that we'll
typically see in the wild and not just
the ones we see in benchmarks
fortunately there are a couple of
benchmarks that are now more
representative of these workloads that
we'd like to optimize for that you see
in real world websites there's
speedometer which simulates a MVC to do
app that with a bunch of standard
JavaScript frameworks and we can test
and see how long chrome and v8 need in
various parts of these semi-realistic
applications and there's also ares six
which is a benchmark that tests e newest
ACMA script feature so es6 features
you'll see that over the last couple
years we've gotten a lot faster with v8
in these workloads that's really good
news because this translates directly to
the type of performance that you would
want to see in your and your website and
on the server side in nodejs one really
important lesson out of all of this is
that what we realized is that if you
have a benchmark that optimizes for
something specific or that shows a
specific problem you will end up
optimizing for that problem and that can
become a little bit of a trap because
optimizations fun we enjoy doing it on
the v8 team but if you have the wrong
goal you will continue to pursue that
goal unless you know when you're done
and you may run the risk of ignoring
other things in the process specifically
what we realized and you saw that in
those graphs before is that the
performance profile of most apps out
there is way it's all across the board
there's time spent in JavaScript parsing
Dom lots of different places and if
you're just specifically optimizing for
one of those slices then you risk not
having a platform that is consistently
performant so there's this concept of
consistently a consistent baseline
performance which is sort of a mantra
that we've had over the last couple of
years
to make sure that not just specific use
cases are fast but that JavaScript and
the web platform and nodejs is fast
across the board make sense okay breathe
so with that in mind I'd like to talk a
little bit about how v8 works and how
we've changed it over the last couple of
years with this new focus on railroad
performance two technologies I'd like to
highlight going in to this discussion
ignition and turbofan we've spent the
last couple of years building
fundamental new technologies into v8
that make it faster in the real world
and across a broader spectrum of of use
cases the first one is the ignition
interpreter the ignition interpreter
gives us the baseline performance the
consistent baseline performance we need
if we're running all sorts of different
JavaScript we have the turbofan
optimising compiler which which takes a
look at the most commonly or the most
frequently executed pieces of code and
then optimizes those selectively with
these two new components we're able to
address a much wider set of use cases
than we did before
I won't dwell into all the details of
what we used to do in v8 but as of
chrome 59 so that's almost about a year
now
these two technologies are the primary
ones in v8 that allow us to address the
performance needs of a broad set of use
cases ok let's talk a little bit about
how v8 uses these two technologies
ignition and turbofan and integrates
them into its pipeline this is a useful
model also thinking back to that that
set of graphs that I showed where the
distribution of x in the different bars
this will kind of show you where those
come from or some of them come from so
how does v8 work well we take your
JavaScript code and it goes through a
parser and that parser turns it into an
abstract syntax tree this is kind of so
standard computer science e stuff and
then that abstract tree syntax tree gets
turned into interpreter bytecode that's
the interpreter bytecode that
gets run through ignition which I
mentioned on the previous slide as we're
running that code through the
interpreter we're not just executing
we're looking for signals from the
executing code that we can use for later
optimization Java scripts kind of a
tricky language it's pretty much on type
it's the Wild West yeah you can create a
variable one time it's an integer next
time it's a string next time it's an
object and there's really no signals to
v8 beforehand what you want what your
intent is or there are a few signals
I'll actually get into that a little bit
more so without those explicit types
that you would find in other language it
v8 has to actually learn a little bit
about your code on the fly before
connect can before it can make you fat
make it faster so what the interpreter
does is it runs your byte code for a
while
collects feedback we call this type
feedback and with that feedback is then
sends the hottest pieces of JavaScript
code to the turbofan compiler where your
JavaScript gets optimized selectively
turned into machine code that runs
really fast so a couple of high-level
observations about this new system and
why it's actually better than what we
did before I'll go back to this this
looks complicated this is actually
pretty simple you notice that there are
arrows here we go from one stage to the
next there are a couple exceptions that
I won't go into here but the idea is
that we can reason about the system
because the units are self-contained and
the interfaces between them are
relatively well defined it wasn't the
case that it wasn't always the case in
v8 that it was quite that clean and that
has helped us have some important ask
for some important attributes to the to
the runtime first of all both ignition
and turbofan support the entire
JavaScript language before these
technologies were shipped it wasn't the
case that we can optimize all the
JavaScript the the ones way that I've
made many of you are some of you may
know of is that try-catch so exceptions
of structured exception handling was not
optimized in older versions of V to be a
problem because it limited with only a
selective set of language functionality
being optimized it limit
what you could do as a developer and
what you could rely on to be fast in
your applications so now turbofan and
ignition optimized the entire JavaScript
language they provide consistent
performance I mentioned the consistent
baseline performance as a sort of a
mantra we believe that with these two
technologies we've solved a couple of
the interesting problems that we used to
have that allow us to give you soft
guarantees about the baseline
performance of your code and I mentioned
simple before I know that that that
picture with the flow of information
through v8 looked like a lot of little
boxes but it used to be that there were
arrows between those boxes that were
sort of unintuitive and difficult to
reason about so with this new system we
were able to create something that was
simpler and more comprehensive than the
the compiler and the compilers that we
had before now this is something that
will become important in the discussion
we have later simplicity and this is one
of the tech takeaways that I'll mention
at the end is simplicity can be your
friend because if you invest too much in
complexity upfront then that complexity
is something you pay for over time again
and again if you create a simple system
at the beginning it's easy to reason
about it's easy to measure it's easy to
actually identify problems with and fix
bugs with and to maintain so despite all
the complicated stuff that's going on v8
it's sort of a design goal that we have
to keep things as simple as possible
necessary complexity but only the
necessary complexity because a simpler
system is just simpler to reason about
simpler to fix and as you build a
complex system and it gets bigger and
bigger
without that simplicity at some point
you're just you're just lost you can no
longer move I talked about feedback and
how we generate or how we optimize code
in v8 based on the feedback we generate
so I'd like to go into a little bit of
depth about how this is done because for
my later examples understanding this
turns out to be important we use this
mechanism called inline caches anybody
ever learn or
heard of a line caches here oh okay Wow
one that's that's that's excellent
so inline caches so this is good that I
talked about this inline cache is our
mechanism that we use to make operations
faster both in the interpreter and to
record type feedback or information that
is necessary for later optimization in
turbo family and I'd like to give you an
example of how this works so this is a
very simple function here that either
returns the first element of array or
undefined depending on the size of the
array I think this is pretty
straightforward code to understand as
you send this code to that pipeline that
I that I outlined before it first
generates byte code and this is what the
byte code looks like so don't sweat the
details of the byte code looks very sort
of assembly language history it kind of
is and I'll get into what is important
here in a few minutes now when we create
the byte code we also build it such that
we can collect information about it as
it runs and there's this thing called
the feedback vector which is sort of
comes hand in hand with the byte code
and to orient you a little bit I'd like
to show how these three pieces sort of
fit together so you'll see that the
first thing we do in the function is ask
for the length of the array and from
that we are from that statement we
generate a byte code in the interpreter
which is also highlighted here called a
name proper name property load the
accumulator with a named property don't
sweat the details here again but you
notice that the zero in the bracket at
the end actually refers to the last one
to an index in this feedback vector and
these highlight its peak portions of the
code here on this slide all sort of
belong together as do these here so the
Equality operator here turns out it's
JavaScript so we don't actually know
beforehand the exact details of how the
Equality operator needs to work at
runtime depending on the types that you
send it so we have to collect feedback
on that as well so for that we have a
byte code and we have a slot in the
feedback that vector to hold the
information as we gather it
so the last operation we have is in the
case that the array is not empty we load
the first element out of it and again
this is a byte code that refers to slots
in the feedback vector so that as we
execute it we can learn and get better
make sense okay so let's see how this
actually works at execution time let's
call that routine that we just within a
ray of integer values and as we go
through I'm gonna focus just on the the
byte codes that that fill in type as we
go through we take a look at what was
actually passed to the interpreter for
particular operations in this case when
you start the function you ask for its
length the length of the array that you
passed in we get that property from the
array object the first time we see it we
inside a v8 and again don't sweat the
details about what these things are
called
we record hey this was a this was an
array of integers we have a internal
term that we use called map in v8 that's
kind of a fancy or not so fancy word for
sort of the class descriptor or the
shape descriptor of the object that it's
currently looking at so in this take
case we're looking at an array of
integers we remember in the first slot
we saw an array of integers the first
time and in order to do that operation
on that array of integers there's a
handler there's a it's code pointer
basically that gets remembered in the
feedback vector that we compute at the
first time the first time we see this a
operation and we store them to type
eject later vector so that later we can
come back and execute it quickly or more
quickly again the second time it also
serves as a placeholder for later opera
with is by filling in the type by
filling in the feedback vector we know
what types we saw on that can be used as
hints to the optimizing compiler second
operation the strict equality check the
length was an integer value so in here
it's a slightly different format in this
slot we just remember it's a it's an
integer that we saw and finally when we
loaded the first element
of the array we remembered the same or
we recorded the same information that we
did when we took the length which is the
shape of the object it's map and we
created a handler or assigned a handler
to that slot and the feedback vector to
say here's the code that actually will
perform that operations given this type
the nice property after the first time
we run through is that this code is what
we call monomorphic so monomorphic means
one shape we for these operations that
can do different things depending on the
types you pass in we have only seen one
type and that's a great thing for v8
because the next time around in the
interpreter when we run it we know what
we saw before we can make some
assumptions about how it's going to work
the next time assuming that it stays the
same and when the optimising compiler
runs later when turbofan runs it can use
these assumptions to make to generate
much better code so this works great for
simple code it gets more complicated
when you start introducing different
types so I'm gonna call first again but
this time with an array of strings and
it turns out the way v8 is implemented
that array of strings looks different in
the implementation under the hood then
the array of numbers did so let's see
what actually happens when we execute
this code the first thing is we execute
the the load of the length of that array
and because it's shaped differently then
the integer array its map is different
and we have to record this fact and the
way we do that is it no longer fits in
line in the feedback vector we have to
allocate a side data structure and we
put both entries in there for the things
that we've seen right so we've seen a
map we've seen the shape of an integer
array and we've seen the shape of an
object array so this information has to
be stored for later fast execution and
interpreter and for optimization but you
see that it's not become a little more
complicated we already had this out of
line structure you can see things are
starting to get a little bit more
complex good news is when we do the
Equality operator
it's still an integer so that stays the
same but when we ask for the first
element
of the array the shape is different and
again we have to record that fact so if
you look at the feedback vector after
you've made both of these calls you have
different entries than you did when you
ran through the first time because we've
seen different types that has caused
certain operations to go what we call
polymorphic many shaped turns out this
is something that has plagued us over
the years polymorphic operations and the
way we handled polymorphism in v8
directly translates to performance how
really complex systems perform if we
handle polymorphism well complex systems
systems tend to get better and faster
and this is something that we wrestle
with and that's important for an example
that I'd like to show you now so given
that background kind of know how v8
works fundamentally how the interpreter
works and how we use the information
gathered from type feedback - it gets
fed into the optimizing compiler and
that polymorphism is something that you
have to watch out for because it can
actually make your code slower this
became acutely aware or we became
acutely aware of this in the example
that I'd like to show you now let's you
need a function in your in your program
that sums all of the elements in
meringue so here's a function that I
wrote by hand using sort of idiomatic
yes six it goes through all of the
elements of an array for the first
element it just remembers it otherwise
it adds it to the element that it saw or
the sum that it had had has collected up
to that point makes sense what I did is
also wrote a little timing routine here
that you can PAP the array - and it
wraps that sum functions and get run it
over over again and get some
statistically significant performance
results and make judgments about how
fast things are okay so that lets
test that routine let's see how fast it
is in v8 so with that handwritten some I
created a integer array and run it
through my benchmark harness and 100
milliseconds to run it I think was about
a million times okay that's pretty good
then I run it again this time with an
array of strings so maybe this is
ringing some bells there's something
gonna be different going on here right
got slower hmm got a lot slower even
though the array is shorter so there's
less work to do but it got slower okay
something's going on there finally I'm
gonna run it again with the integer
array that I passed through past the
first time ouch that's really slow is
this expected would you want your
program to do this right this is not the
consistent baseline performance we're
hoping for which is you do something
once you do it again and you get the
same results both in correctness and in
in performance okay so what's what's
going on here why is this so slow
anybody any guesses polymorphism and we
talked about why this is kind of a trap
that v8 can fall into you'll notice that
in the iteration of some function one of
the things that is done is it fetches
each of the elements and we use this
construct this for of construct which
under the covers does nothing more than
sort of that that work that I did before
where it looks at the length of the
array and it takes the current element
that it's on out of the array it under
the covers requires the same machinery
that we saw in the example that I showed
before and it runs it has the same
dangers the hidden dangers that if you
pass it to arrays of different types
then it generates polymorphism for those
operations it even gets a little more
subtle in this and than that because
when we sum the elements together the
operator for doing plus in in JavaScript
wears many hats and it can be a integer
addition
in which case you get integer addition
or it can be string concatenation which
is a little surprising but it works that
way so the first time we run the sum
function with integer array we get an
integer result and that plus is an
integer operation the second time though
just like we saw a polymorphism when
fetching the elements from the array
when we add the elements out of that
array together first time they're
integer second time they're strings we
have to have a more complex
implementation it becomes polymorphic it
becomes slower so this is why the
handwritten implementation is slow okay
maybe the VA team can do this better
right we have these things called
built-ins if you know JavaScript
reasonably well you know that that the
prototypes of many of the built-in
objects have a whole bunch of utility
Fink functions and those functions are
defined in great detail in the Ekman
script spec if you read through the spec
it says this is exactly what it's going
to do when you call a for each or this
is exactly what we're going to do when
you call array index of and the the good
thing about that is that because we have
this contract defined by a cluster
script you think that gives the VM
implementers the v8 engineers a lot of
opportunity to make those built-ins
faster because they get shipped with v8
we can sort of do all the tricks
beforehand and you can benefit by using
those built-ins using all that sort of
that we put in to those right ok so
turns out there's a built in for this
and it's the reduce built in so this is
using es6 syntax I got a little arrow
function here I've idiomatically
expressed what I was trying to do in the
sum function a little higher level I've
expressed my intent by using the reduce
built-in on the array and provided this
arrow function to tell it what did you
do for each element so what this sum
function in essence does is exactly what
the handwritten code does but it sort of
wraps my intent in a language construct
an explicit language statement which is
one of these built-ins of the language
that is well define its behaviors well
find so you think wow this could be
faster right this is gonna be better
because the v8 engineers have taken care
of this well if you run the same
benchmark that I had before
up until chrome 58 here's what happens
integer array that hurt
Kathir result right though run it with
strings
okay marginally better but still not
great and a third time through faster
what's going on here okay that's about
almost five times slower than doing it
by hand so why would you use a built in
all that specialty knowledge we have
seemed to have not helped it's
unfortunate why well up until chrome 58
many of our built-ins and specifically
this reduced buildin were what we call
self hosted it's sort of a seductive
idea of when you're building a VM to say
you know what we're gonna build one
compiler we're gonna build one
interpreter and if we express everything
in terms of JavaScript no matter what it
is then those in that interpreter and
that that that optimising compiler I'll
just take care of it right it won't be
our problem because the compiler smart
enough
so the reduce built in was written like
this
up until chrome 58 and you'll see it's
considerably longer than the handwritten
version the reason for that is because
the ACMA script specification for this
built in is actually pretty long and has
a lot of edge cases a lot of things that
have to be dealt with and expressing
that as JavaScript there's an impedance
mismatch anyway regardless of that that
it's a little bit longer you still have
fundamentally the same problems there's
polymorphism it probably morphism in
this code because it's JavaScript code
if you use self-hosting to represent
sort of these really common built in
pieces of functionality you run the same
risks in the built-ins that you would
get in your application code so what's
the observation don't pills don't self
host built-ins
optimize them for them optimize them and
sort of the observation here is a little
deeper than that and goes back to sort
of my original observation at the
beginning of the presentation which is
if something's going to be important for
performance or anything else premature
optimization or even sort of building a
mental model around something you think
you will use later to optimize in this
case we thought we're gonna have a great
compiler we're gonna have a great
interpreter it'll just solve this
problem for us that's pushing off
technical debt that's sort of making
assumptions which can come around later
and bite you which they did in this case
so another way to look at this is say
well if it's really important for
performance why don't we build a
solution which is at which is customized
for the use case we have so that's turns
out what we did over the last couple
years that's I want to talk to you a
little bit about how we did that because
I think it's kind of cool it's a little
bit shows you under the hood what we're
actually doing in v8 to make these
faster you might ask okay
since the built-ins are so commonly used
in so many different cases and we have
the specialty knowledge about them
because we're vm engineers and we have
this specification we could do all this
work in advance would it be great if we
had super tight control over what was
generated in the built-in because in the
JavaScript code there's sort of this
abstraction that we when we did the self
hosted built-in we sort of lost
information there was an in piece
impedance mismatch we lost sort of the
expression of the tent like this is
important to get fast and maybe use some
tricks here you couldn't do that in in
the JavaScript self hosted built-in if
there was a way we could exercise that
in a much lower level that would be
great right so maybe JavaScript is not
the right tool for that how about we use
C++ right we could implement these
built-ins in C++ well it turns out
that's kind of tricky there's a couple
reasons why I can't do that
the first one is inside of v8 when we're
executing executing JavaScript code we
have an ABI we have a sort of an
interface the way code calls each other
inside of Java while executing
JavaScript that um
different than the C++ ABI and because
they're different it's really hard to
interoperate without a bunch of extra
machinery turns out that machine return
is it's expensive enough from a
performance perspective that it's really
not a good idea to do that in most
circumstances there's also this thing
called deferred code if we have a
built-in that has fast paths
incorporated into it for example if you
are iterating over something that's an
array you can pass in in the case of the
reduce built-in you could have passed it
something that wasn't an array and xmas
defines exactly what happens in
that and that situation but if it is an
array we know we can do that pretty fast
and pretty quickly we like to express
this in our built-ins where we have a
fast path we run some checks and if
those checks hold we do the fast common
code otherwise we go somewhere else do
something much more expensive and then
jump back and resume where it makes
sense all right so they have the inline
fast path outline slow path hard to do
this in C++ because you actually
literally want the fast path to be
inline you want to control how the
compiler generates the code tough to do
in C++ we also have a GC a garbage
collector in v8 and one of the things we
want to do is be able to have pointers
that are not just to you know data
structures on the c++ heap we want to
have pointers that are to objects and
because of our GC r GC actually moves
objects it compacts it moves them around
for efficiency it's important that we
know where each one of those object
pointers are and handle it specially in
case there's a garbage collection and
it's really difficult to do that in C++
it's oh it's very difficult to sort of
specify there's a pointer here and it's
going to be an object pointer and no
matter what happens you have to tell me
when you do anything with that pointer
in the compiler and the C++ compiler it
it just doesn't work you have to build
an indirection that gets really
expensive doesn't work another thing we
do built-ins is we do these we do tail
calling it's sort of a variant of this
deferred code will inline the common
case after doing some checks and if we
can't handle it at all
we'll then tail call out of the fast
implementation into a C++ implementation
that has all these disadvantages but we
don't care because it almost never
happens we just need the slow
implementation to be spec compliant
okay so C++ isn't the right tool how
about we write everything in assembly
language right that's fast they have all
that control turns out for a while we
kind of did this and we accumulated like
45,000 lines of assembly code per
platform we have like nine of them and
if you can imagine it's sort of turned
into a mess after a while because it's
really hard to sort of express intent
when writing assembly language you can
only express nuts and bolts so it turns
out that's not really a good idea either
so is there something we can do instead
let's take the idea from the handwritten
platform built-ins these assembly ones
that we had they were really fast but
impossible to maintain is there
something that we can sort of do that's
better than that it has all the
advantages but maybe is less complex
easier to manage well turns out we can
so turbofan we have this compiler
technology that has the ability to
generate machine code optimized machine
code on nine different platforms and it
has this intermediate representation
that represents operations at a high
level add these two 32-bit numbers load
this value out of memory make this call
to this function and by exposing that
interface in the right way we can
describe exactly what we want to do at
almost an assembly level but in the
cross-platform way and so the interface
or the component that does this we call
the code stub assembler just to be
really confusing because we call things
sometimes stubs and sometimes built-ins
it's it's a mess but anyway we build
built-ins with the codes to have
assembler okay let's go down to sort of
the checks each sheet what this gives us
GC support turns out doing this in
assembly language is really hard because
you have the same problems as you
wouldn't c++ somehow annotating things
explicitly this thing in this register
at this time is an object Wow that gets
really difficult to maintain turns out
and the code stop assembler when you
create values and you manage them part
of the interface allows you to express
hey this thing's gonna be an object and
it will be for its entire lifetime just
do the right thing for me and by the way
put it in a register if you can right do
the right thing so you get that for free
register allocation sort of just
mentioned mention that one of my
colleagues likes to call the handwritten
Assembly version of register allocation
in brain register allocation turns out
it's really hard to do you get it wrong
all the time and it creates almost
impossible to find bugs because we have
an optimizing compiler and turbofan if
we use the back end for that which has a
register allocator you don't have to
grapple with these problems in the in
writing stubs with the code sub-assembly
because the register allocation is done
for you it's done by machine and not in
brain all those sort of impedance
mismatches that I mentioned with the ABI
with calling back and forth between
built-ins and JavaScript code they're
gone in asan if you write things by hand
and assembly language it's very
difficult to maintain very hard to do in
the CSA you basically just create a
descriptor and say hey I want to call
this function and it has this particular
set of parameters put these registers in
the right place from these values or
whatever just do the right thing and it
generates that code for you on nine
platforms when you would have to do that
by hand if you wrote them in assembly
language we have some pretty neat
optimizations in the back end of all of
our code generators so we do instruction
selection which means on Intel platforms
we can sort of combine addressing modes
make them much more efficient we have an
instruction scheduler which is something
that's really hard to do by hand and
assembly our instruction scheduler
creates a model of the simplified model
of the processor and figures out if I
reorder some of these instructions will
you get faster code doing this at scale
in assembly language really hard and
last thing there's tool integration
turns out that the
as a the code sub assembler can generate
the right records that associates with
the code that it generates so that you
can use the Linux perf integration to
see where we're spending time inside of
these built-ins if you do that in
assembly you would have to build these
records by hand totally unmaintainable
so this is a great thing right with this
code some assembler we can now generate
at scale for all of our platforms these
built-ins that are custom customized for
the functionality that we need so how
did this turn how does this turn out the
end at the end of the day well so let's
try that integer array again
with chrome 63 which just has the CSA
version of the reduce built in right so
it has a customized version written with
the CSA interface that generates pretty
good assembly code for nine platforms so
you run the first time hmm well that's
not great there's still something going
on here no I don't know where that C
came from anyway um but for the string
case we're faster already that's good
why could this be the case hmm get to
that in a second um yeah because the C
that's right so I'm not advising you to
randomly add C code to your Java Script
that was totally not on purpose that was
no anyway good news consistency it's
when you run the integer array through
it again it's consistent there's a happy
ending to this story so bear with me
there's more we could do what was going
on while we were still slow for those
for the integer array well there's
actually two things in play here
remember that example I showed you
originally with reduce it calls this
arrow function for each element that we
have so you can imagine as time goes on
we start by calling the reduce function
we spend some time in it does some setup
and some checking and whatever and then
it calls back the callback function to
do the work adds two numbers and it goes
back
and it goes back to arrow function adds
two numbers goes back mm-hmm
right so you get the idea here I won't
go through all of it but goes back and
forth bunch so so what's the problem the
problem is is that calling back and
forth between the reduce built-in which
is really fast now
but that arrow function has a lot of
overhead that overhead if the work that
you're doing inside of the arrow
function that plus operation is very
small the calling back and forth is
actually much more expensive than the
actual that the work that you do in
inside of the call back hmm
so how do we solve this problem well we
have this optimizing compiler turbofan
and what we've done is we've taught
turbofan that when it sees a call to
reduce and it knows that the function
that is called back meet certain
criterion and it's small enough and the
phase of the moon aligns and it's the
third Tuesday of every month
that it can inline the operation and it
generates when you send your code then
to the optimizing compiler it generates
one piece of code for all of the reduce
including the inline version of the call
back so it looks more like this right so
instead of calling back and forth
there's one chunk of optimized generated
machine code that does both I can
probably yeah guess actually oh yeah one
thing to add here we talked about
polymorphism being a bad thing turns out
there's some tricks we can play in
optimizing apado by the time we get
around to optimizing we could have
recorded that by the way at this place
that you call reduced it only ever gets
called with an integer array and it
remembers that in the place in the code
that you call reduce so if you have one
part of your code that does string
operations with reduce and another part
of your code that does you know it has
integer arrays that it works on those
two things will be handled separately
and the type feedback will be separated
in such a way that we can specialize and
make it monomorphic for those call sites
all right punchline time so let's do it
let's do the benchmark again
this time being in line by turbofan
pretty good oh yeah that's me
thanks but anyway let's do it for the
string we're good
interesting to note here that it's
actually faster than the integer array
kind of makes sense it's a smaller array
it should be doing less work and running
it again not perfect still pretty good I
it's honest right I'm it's still better
than anything we saw before so let's
take a look at these numbers in
comparison the first one is let's start
out with the self-hosted built-in that
we would have had in chrome 58 and
before using that test the integer array
first time string array second time and
then the third of the the third test was
integer array a second time as a
baseline the self-hosted built-in is one
so anything that gets faster than that
is smaller so smaller is better the
first thing you notice here is if you
have a handwritten version but you use
it as a library right you have we had
that handwritten sum function if you use
it in a bunch of different places then
it's great if your monomorphic the first
time you call it it's super it's really
fast but you see it gets progressively
worse as your code becomes more complex
that's not predictable baseline
performance okay with the CSA
monomorphic case is slower but
immediately in complex code if you're
dealing with strings or you're dealing
with polymorphism it's already faster
than the self-hosted built in and
comparable if not faster than the
version that's handwritten and finally
if you use the turbofan inlined version
in chrome 66 or later you'll see that
it's faster than any of them it's faster
than the handwritten version in the
monomorphic case why this is an
important thing this remember I told you
we have this special technology because
we read the spec and stuff turns out
that if you look at the reduce function
in the specification it leaves out some
of the steps that you might have to
actually technically do to be correct if
you use your handwritten loop so we have
opportunities to operate or to optimize
that you may not
have in hand written code so important
lesson learned here Express intent the
reason these built-ins these
higher-order functions are there is to
allow you to say what you want to do at
a high level and let the compiler try to
optimize it with your intent and not
trying to figure out what your intent
was like we did in the self hosted
built-ins from the individual statements
that were made one really nice aspect of
the reduce built-in and many other ones
actually at this point chrome 66 or
later low - it's a great library that
for a long time was the only way to get
really good performance for some of the
array built-ins if you compare low - now
against the latest version of a v8 with
ignition and turbofan and these in
lining of the buildings it's much faster
to use v8s built-ins and not the sort of
these standard workaround solutions
that's great news okay time for
takeaways design minimally and
specifically this is a lesson we learned
the very hard way don't over optimize
prematurely optimize or build complexity
into something that you may never need
right idiomatic JavaScript use the
features that are provided with es6 and
new versions of the javascript
javascript language because they allow
you to express your intent at a high
level which gives us more opportunity to
optimize your code choose the right
benchmarks because those benchmarks will
come around to haunt you if they're the
wrong ones measure and tune carefully
spend time actually creating a framework
that measures the things that you care
about so that you could do it
iteratively and get better on the things
you care about that's it thank you very
much